tim davies left home today
thinking he'd be getting the first of
two doses of the fisa vaccine
he was devastated when he got to the
clinic and was told his second jab set
for 21 days time
had been postponed i was
quietened uh my heart had been bumping
with enthusiasm and delight
and it slowed down and i came out um
pensive and i wasn't smiling behind my
mouse when i spoke to my wife
she knew say to whether something was
and i said i'm very worried about what
is happening
i'm not sure that the the this regime is
the one that the
regulator authority sanctioned when they
gave the office of the
go ahead for this faction yesterday the
government changed its guidelines on the
fisa vaccine
the advice had been to give two doses
within three weeks of each other
for best protection now they say within
three months
and gps told us the change is at best
confusing
at worst off-putting when you're going
through the consent and explaining the
treatment and the importance of getting
that second vaccine
and the importance of having it three to
four weeks afterwards and now suddenly
the news comes out that that's changed
and don't worry it is fine just to have
it 12 weeks later
i think that's going to cause a lot of
worry and confusion amongst patients
the new government strategy aims to get
more people
a first dose faster but does that
compromise protection
pfizer says their 95 coverage is based
on two doses within
21 days and that the safety and efficacy
of the vaccine has not been evaluated on
different dosing schedules
there are no data to demonstrate that
protection after the first dose
is sustained after 21 days
in response the mhra which says how and
what vaccines can be used told us the
new advice
was based on clinical trial data that
showed the vaccine was 90.5
effective against preventing covid19
after the first dose
and there was no evidence to suggest
that the effectiveness of the vaccine is
declining
towards the end of the 21 day period
and virologist julian tang believes in
this crisis situation
it is the best approach we know from the
collective experience of you know
decades of vaccine
vaccination experience that the first
those
immune response will not disappear if
you don't have the second
dose within three weeks this first
dose initiative is actually not a bad
idea to try and
suppress the virus from overwhelming
healthcare services
and infecting the vulnerable before we
can get to them with even the first dose
so you know a pandemic situation
requires some flexibility
and i think this is not unreasonable
given the situation
that's a situation where speed and
efficacy have to be balanced
nearly a million people have had the
covert 19 vaccine so far
there are many millions to go katrina
patosi sky news